[Music]
all right let's go to renee in
waynesboro
renee what's up renee
hi how are you i'm dr john how are we
doing i'm good how are you i'm just
we're figuring it out having fun you
doing well
yes sorry i got a little bit of a throat
thing going on hey no problem so what's
up how can i help
so i'm i'm doing great i graduated last
week and i'm looking for a job would you
graduate
i'm a i'll be a psychiatric nurse
practitioner once i take my board
congratulations you're a real
professional that's fantastic
thank you that's so great good for you
thank you and my last clinical which is
like an internship was uh with this
really great psychiatrist which is where
my question comes in um everything's
going great finished clinical
a couple days later he sent me this
long-winded message about how he has
feelings for me
which i do not have for him
um so my question is like
if i feel pretty okay with it can i go
ahead and still take a job i have an
interview at the end of the month at the
same clinic it's not his clinic but he
works there
talk about cringy so um
yeah
so
i've got so many feelings before we go
forward i just have to say
i'm so sorry that you got put in this
position
yeah i was kind of i'm i'm kind of angry
about it hey listen
be super angry about it be
furious about it because i'm pissed
on behalf of that's a if you haven't had
a clinical rotation supervisor like you
have i had one
those relationships are
i wish was a better word they're very
intimate right because people are
walking you through like you're helping
people you lose people you get scared
you have hard conversations what do you
feel like those are deep relationships
and so when somebody's a clinical
supervisor
um they have to
be so above board
understanding the power hierarchy there
and understanding this the sword they
wield over their their
i'm just sick man i'm so sorry that's
wrong at every every level across
everything so how did how did this come
about just out of the blue sends you
this long message
well
so everything you just said right and
then we did get close we i thought we're
good friends he was a great mentor
i felt really good about everything he's
so intelligent he to the point he sort
of to me kind of teeters that line
between
he's essential he's very eccentric um
and i think i don't want to presume to
tell someone how they feel but i think
he just got a little confused because i
consider myself very nonjudgmental so
when he says like shares weird things
about his experiences or the way he
thinks i'm like oh okay well tell me
more you know that's why i'm in this
profession i think it's interesting i
don't care if you're a little bit odd
you know
um and so maybe that friendliness or
that that openness came across
in a way that he misread
i
i i'm so sorry and i know this is your
experience i got to stop you is that
okay
yeah
not my fault i want you to own zero of
this
right yeah if you were flirty and you
were like
man
you and me when this rotation's over
we are going to burn the city to the
ground like if that had been you
it's his
oh you're saying no way no way
no no well and so like i like i say i
was i was nice to him and that's about
the only thing i can think that maybe he
misconstrued
and i should mention he's also
20 some maybe 24 5 years older than me
and i'm married to a female
so
which you talked about so there is no uh
dumb and dumber so you're telling me
there's a chance right that that's
there's not even
right so listen uh to go back
if you had been trying as his um
clinical subordinate as one of his
students if you will
to hook up with him
he has an ethical obligation
to no longer be
your supervisor and to bring that to
some sort of border at board of ethics
and so often there's hard conversations
about like when people get relationship
stuff and mixed signals and i've been in
enough
um
sexual assault investigations over my
career that some of those are very clear
some of those are very very messy that's
just the truth
this is not and here's because of the
power hierarchy
he is the clinical supervisor and so if
somebody was to come on to him in a
predator if you were bananas as a
predator it's his job to create the
space backwards and to call in your
ethics and in your uh character and
fitness not
to be like oh really maybe you know what
i mean it's just the whole thing's gross
and i hate this for you because here's
why
there really is not a non-messy way
forward for you
yeah and i hate that how old are you
35 okay so you've i mean you're not 23
and so you know this but i'm just gonna
spell it out is that okay
yeah
you're either
gonna pretend this never happened and
it's gonna eat your soul
the rage the anger will get loud right
or
um
you're going to apply for this job and
you're going to get it and you're going
to see this dude and you're going to try
to be like ah sounds cool
and
i may be overstating this but i don't
think i am um you would be the one to
finally to speak to this but
that same fight-or-flight reflex will
that's supposed to trigger when there's
a bear at the door will understand that
every time you pull into that parking
lot there's that bear there
that is potentially going to use his
power and influence and and
superiority as a supervising physician
to put me in a position that i want to
be in right um or
um you decide to burn his career to the
ground which it should be
and
um that may be too strong of a statement
i don't i'm just so grossed out by this
and so i'm making sweeping statements
here you're going to burn his
his situation down his career down
and then you're going to be that person
in the off you know what i'm saying
there's just not a messy way forward and
i hate that for you
i do too because well there's a few
other things so
but wait there's more
i'm trying to rationalize because
there's just not many jobs where i'm at
and i do want to work yeah so here's my
rationalization tell me if it's crazy so
he worked part-time there and part-time
a different place
and the part-time at this clinic is two
different locations so the one location
that i would be at is only there once a
week
now
if i go full time i can do four days a
week so maybe i could just avoid them um
this is
like
i'm sure i would still no no you're a
night you're a psychiatric nurse
practitioner
i know you're on the other end of this
of
do you have just listen to the words
you're saying
i know
you will be on the other end of this
interview with
countless number of patients and the
clients in the future
and you'll hear yourself
maybe if i just don't wear this
particular thing on this day
then he won't be tempted to or maybe if
i you hear what's happening
here yeah
yeah
and it happens to the best of us i've
been there too
where you start back well maybe if i j
dude i'm so sick for you so here's my
here's my
six foot two
white
male 200 pound guy okay
i walk in and
full of bluster and texas ego and i sit
down with the hr director and say i'm a
finalist for this position
and i'm going to print out all those
texts and say and this just happened and
i really want this job and i deserve
this job and my record that you all have
on file suggests that i'm qualified for
this job
but i can't be here because this guy is
a predator because here's what my
experience working as an administrator
and and um
like with my experience with as
administrator with law students in a
similar character and fitness thing is
if this if this were to be made known my
guess is you're not the first
no that's sad that's strange too
this is probably a pattern of behavior
if this person's what fifth sixty right
58
and they've spent their career
mentoring young students i wouldn't
surprise me if this is is not
maybe you are the angel snowflake
unicorn that came from heaven just to be
in his rotation but um my guess is this
is a pattern of behavior
but i can't tell you that's the right
path
right
because they can also say um you're not
hired
and then you're gonna have a lawsuit and
you'll probably actually win it
but the question would be for what right
right
yeah and so let me ask you this
[Applause]
this guy needs to have his license taken
away at least or at least not be allowed
to work with students anymore
okay my thought is usually once
unethical in one area they're unethical
across the board but i feel pretty
strongly about this and for people
listening and you're like dude chill out
he just asked a girl out that he was
working
you got to just trust me and i can hear
it in your voice renee the the
relationship between a supervisor and
their
practicum students is so intimate and
it's so heavy and it's so power laden
right because any moment he could have
written
do not does not she's not meeting
standard or
uh does not have good bedside manner and
it's hard to quantify those things and
you're just out on your ear right so
the fact that somebody's praying on you
and with and you're rather vulnerable in
that relationship it just grosses me out
man he's got to be better than that so
where do you want to be when this is
over
my clinical he did wait till i finish so
i'll give him that oh how sweet i do
agree with you thank you for just
defending him
he does know that i was i had an
interview there later this month
so i do have an interview there to do
that so yeah it's still kind of yeah
um
so what you're i mean clearly you're
brilliant where do you want to where do
you want to be what do you want to do
well that's kind of why i want to go
there because they're offering me
um
the opportunity to work from
kids adults elderly developmental delay
intellectually like across the board is
where i would have experienced that i
could see you know what i want to do
let me ask you a hard question
yeah who do you want to be when this is
over
oh well
it's i mean professionally i just i
really want to be a really great
practitioner like i want i really want
to dig into my career
and
i just want to i don't really want to
put him under professionally
unless it were to continue to be a
problem or something you know he put
himself under as far as i'm concerned
but i i also get your sentiment um
that's why i have to that's why in these
kind of situations i gotta be careful
because
um
i have a particular disdain for some of
this that not everybody shares and i'm
not in the middle of that situation
the other side of it is um
let me take a more graceful approach
but you know him better than better than
i do
say you walk in and say hey i got your
message dude
we can't have this
right is that a possibility
it was a message a text message and i
said i i respect you as a professional
colleague and
and it'll never be anything else and i
haven't heard anything else
um
so i mean i did put i i was very direct
and and that's been the end of it so far
so
um
yet
has this happened to you before
unwanted advances
yes i'm a woman in america thank you you
idiot
um
uh
yeah i i mean
not that as much as um
the power differential
no well no i take that back yes one i
had a nursing supervisor who i was
working with
and um
that was also very inappropriate he was
also much older and i basically did the
same thing i just shut it down okay
yeah
so when i ask you who do you want to be
at the end of this here's what i'm
getting at
some people can be comfortable
uh i didn't want to say that
i guess i just seem to say i'm sorry
this happened to you now you're in a
funky position
um i'm very uncomfortable with unwanted
male attention if that's what you mean
and it makes me very uncomfortable yes
and you lay on top of that a significant
power right because this is a
supervising
physician so six months from now you're
working there and you write a report
and he tries again and you say no and he
writes
this person is not doing what they're
supposed to be doing that becomes part
of your file
right and so that's what i don't i don't
like the the end of where this can go
because even if you take this job as an
np
you're still quote unquote under his
supervisor supervisory authority correct
yeah and i think there is one other
doctor there but he's not there very
often at all so i don't know if he could
be my collaborator or not and for the
listener let's make this even more
complicated psychiatrists are hard to
come by
and so it's not like the hospital is
going to be like shoot get that guy out
here we got a new guy here on monday
they would say hey we have to do the
right thing and get rid of this person
oh and by the way there's nobody else to
fill that spot
well i shouldn't say that i haven't
talked to anybody about it but so let me
ask you this what are you going to
do no
that's why i called you doctor
oh man
i'm um
leaning towards just if you're not gonna
like this i'm leaning towards just doing
it
but um i don't i don't know that that's
the best decision and just kind of
between a rock and hard so so
let me give you some piece here
what i'm gonna like is the decision that
you choose you're grown up and you're
brilliant okay
um
i will ask you to do a couple of things
yeah number one
keep a printed record of every single
thing
every text message every response every
email all those things
okay
um if for some reason you go in and
don't get this job
i think you have every reason to believe
it's because you shunned his advances
and at that point
if i'm you if you're my sister you're my
daughter i'm telling you
um
you've got to go make your concerns
heard
if um
yeah i can't tell you to go burn it down
just because there's so many variables
to that situation um i just want you to
do this follow your gut because you're
smart
um
make sure you've got somebody that
you're talking to as you walk into this
okay
yeah and please please please don't bury
who you are and your value and your
worth for a job
okay
all right
you promised me that
yeah i do okay
you're right
man i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i wish
there was a it's one of those calls i
wish there was like some great like and
then and then yeah
it's going to be a mess
because like again again i can talk
about something i keep thinking you're
going to bring these forward and he's
going to have five things that he's like
no she said this and then she did this
and like i keep going back to dumb and
dumber and then she touched my leg and
then there's like a thing and then a
thing
and then it's gonna end in some hr
stalemate and there's gonna be a letter
in his file that's gonna be like we
and then you've got an awkward work
situation and uh this it just goes on
and on and on so i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
yuck
yuck
ladies and gentlemen if you are in a
position of power over somebody
you are
if you take a
employment position over somebody or a
leadership position over somebody as an
employee if you take a supervisory
relationship over somebody as a student
or whatever
you are
making the choice that we will never be
romantically engaged particularly if
they're gonna come back and work for me
um
wow what a mess i'm so sorry renee do
this let me know how it goes let me know
when you get the job let me know how the
conversation goes and let me know what
your next steps are um i'll be thinking
about this one